what's this one now it's a dance of
dragons a true telling
by grand master monken well that sounds
like a proper story
what's it about it's the story of the
fight between ronira targaryen and her
half by the reagan for control of the
seven kingdoms
both of them thought they belonged on
the iron throne when people started
declaring for one of them or the other
their fight divided the kingdoms in two
brothers fought brothers
dragons fought dragons
by the time it was over thousands were
dead
and it was the disaster for the
targaryens as well they never truly
recovered
the deaths of dragons
why is that a dance it's just what they
call it
it makes sense i think it's poetic
rhaenyra targaryen was murdered by her
brother or
rather his dragon it ate her while her
son watched
what's left of her is buried in the
crips right down there
if you'd had to choose
between lunira and aegon
who would you have i wouldn't have
chosen either
saw the choosing sides that made
everything so horrible sometimes a
person has to choose
the dance began as many dancers do with
an old man and a young girl
the queen had failed to produce a son
for her king so he anointed his daughter
the princess rhaenyra as his heir but
years later
the king remarried and his new wife
queen alicent of house hightower
gave him a son feeble and foolish the
old king refused to change the
succession
he didn't even see how his cord had
split into two rival camps of blacks and
greens
after the dresses of the princess and
the queen had worn to some tawny
[Music]
one night a servant found the old king
had died in his sleep
and ran to inform queen alicent protocol
dictated that the bells would be rung
and a raven sent to dragonstone to
summon the air princess rhaenyra for her
coronation
but alison had other plans the lord
commander of the kingsguard sir
christian
cole summoned the small council to
inform them of the king's death
sir otto hightower the hand of the king
and father to queen alicent
demanded that the succession be settled
immediately
the decrepit old men of the small
council were confused
the succession was settled in their
minds the old king had forced the lords
of westeros to swear fealty to princess
rhaenyra as his heir
but sir kristen cole rightly pointed out
that a son
comes before a daughter the council
argued until dawn
when the master of coin finally stood up
and declared he would have no part of
treason
sir kristen cole wisely opened his
throat with a dagger
ending the debate none were more
surprised to hear of prince aegon's
succession than prince aegon himself
at first the fool rejected the crown but
his mother pointed out that his sister
rhaenyra would return such loyalty by
taking his head when ravens carried the
news of aegon's coronation to
dragonstone
princess rhaenyra summoned her own black
council
with her was her uncle and husband damon
targaryen considered by many to be the
most dangerous man in westeros
few lords supported her but the greatest
of these was corliss valerian who
controlled the largest fleet in the
realm
and his targaryen wife rhaenys the old
king's sister
then there were her five sons although
none grown to manhood
a pitiful assembly really combined they
couldn't match the power of house
hightower alone
but rhaenyra had dragons
she damon and rhaenys rode huge and
formidable beasts
and three of her five sons were riders
as well
dragonstone also housed six more dragons
without riders
against this king aegon had only four
dragons of his own
dragons can burn a city but only armies
can take and hold it
if she was to prevail rhaenyra
desperately needed the support of the
few great houses not already sworn to
aegon
her eldest son jacarys flew to the vale
in the north
her middle son lucerus flew to the
stormlands rhaenyra hoped that the war
would begin
and if the gods were good end
with diplomacy as always
they weren't go on pop and tell the bomb
mother that the lord of storm's end is
not a dog she can whistle up
as haman's false eye gleamed at him the
princeling fled the castle and mounted
his young
dragon arax the rain fell in sheets
and great bolts of lightning lit the
world brightest day
arrax was struggling to stay aloft in
the gale
when a roar shook the very foundations
of storm's end
eamonn rose through the clouds and below
him
the monstrous veigar prince lucas
fell broken to be swallowed by the waves
with his death the war of ravens came to
an end
and the war of fire and blood began
when rhaenyra heard of her son's death
she collapsed
she considered ending the war right then
until a raven arrived from her husband
damon
her son would be avenged a son
for a son rhaenyra shipped her two
youngest sons across the narrow sea for
their protection
only for her youngest to return days
later clinging to the neck of his
wounded and dying dragon
he and his brother had been set upon by
an enemy fleet just off dragonstone
defying his mother's command rhaenyra's
eldest son and heir jaekerus
mounted his dragon vermax and flew to
rescue his other brother and punished
the enemy fleet
but the foolish boy let vermax be hooked
like a trout
and dragged into the sea where he soaked
up even more arrows than seawater
his brother disappeared over the horizon
or beneath the waves
no one could say for sure with the loss
of four dragons
rhaenyra's only advantage was fading
luckily for her
over the centuries house targaryen had
spilled more than blood on dragonstone
she promised gold and title to any of
the targaryen bastards who could tame
the six
unclaimed dragons on the island these
bastards were called the dragon seeds
though most were called supper and
perhaps the dragons were eventually
sated
or bored but four of them accepted
riders and were enlisted in rhaenyra's
cause
one day king's landing looked up and saw
two dragons circling their foul
city damon and rhaenyra had come for her
throne
for the city was defenseless eamonn had
taken the king's army from the city
and worse he'd taken his dragon vaga
seeing that resistance was hopeless the
small council
surrendered the city the queen mother
alicent
and the broken queen helena but not king
aegon
somehow despite his wounds and delirium
he had vanished from the city and so
queen rhaenyra climbed the steps and
seated herself on the iron throne
legend has it that as she left the hall
later blood trickled down her legs and
hens
proving the iron throne had spurned her
nonsense it's a chair made of steel
blades
rhaenyra had wanted it all her life and
had sacrificed two sons for it
she likely gripped the damn thing too
tight
back in king's landing queen rhaenyra
didn't have much time to grieve for her
stupid husband
the mad former queen helena flung
herself from a balcony
to be impaled upon the iron spikes
lining the moat of maegor's holdfast
that night the city rose in riot against
rhaenyra
demanding justice for queen helena and
her murdered son among other
foolish peasant fantasies in the midst
of this chaos
a one-handed fool called the shepherds
began to rant against dragons
not just the ones of the enemy but all
dragons everywhere
as he pointed to the dragonpit above on
the hill he shouted
there the demons dwell this is their
city if you would make it yours
first you must destroy them by the time
the first of the attackers came pouring
in
all four were roused awake and angry
nobody knows how many men and women died
that night
who cares they all should have trapped
within the pit
the dragons could not fly instead they
fought with horns
claws teeth and fire for every man who
died
ten more appeared shouting that the
dragons must die
one by one they did finally the last
remaining
dragon broke her chain spread her wings
and flew straight up at the great dome
trying to flee already weakened by
dragonflame
the dome cracked under the force of
impact and then tumbled down
crushing dragon slayers and herself
high atop the red keep queen rhaenyra
clutched her two remaining sons to her
as she watched the end of a family's
might
too afraid of the peasants to defend her
dragons
at least her older son joffrey had a
man's spine
he stole his mother's dragon cyrax and
tried to fly it to the dragon pit to
save his birthright
but the stupid beast didn't understand
and twisted beneath him fighting to be
free of the little boy
until it was weeping for her lost
son more than her dragons rhaenyra
abandoned the iron throne
and sold her crown to buy passage for
her and her last
son back to dragonstone rhaenyra hoped
to hatch more dragons from the eggs in
the castle
but when she landed the welcoming party
slew her guards
and marched her and her son at spear
point to the castle
to face a dead man and a dying dragon
sister king aegon second of his name
called out to rhaenyra
rook's rest had left aegon bent and
twisted
his once handsome face puffy from milk
of the poppy
with burn scars covering half his body
rhaenyra ever defiant told her dear
brother that she'd hoped he was dead
after you aegon answered
then sunfire bathed her
in a blast of flame and devoured her
in six bites when the sun watched
leaving the seventh and final bite her
lower leg
for the stranger
[Music]
you